nos tout le monde sait squeeze
aujourd'hui sur lost in the forest qui
veut dire perdu dans la forêt si tu
n'arrives pas à traduire ça je
t'autorise avoir se tait et rempli de
doliprane à d'objets de l'argent très
bien c'est une sorte de stand-up où tu
deal avec cela alors que c'est que ça un
pneu watts d'accord très bien voilà donc
c'est la spécificité a par contre je
marchais de haller ah c'est vrai qu'un
pneu c'est loin [ __ ] il n'a pas le
plus tôt de la voiture où il a le dos du
gros tracteurs de faire vivre mon gars
qui sait que ça mais je vais adresser
des folles est ce que c'est une blague
ok très bien alors faut trouver des
pages aussi bien évidemment bien pour le
moment je suis en train de faire une
sorte de de slide sur les ventes dans
les herbes assez génial on s'amuse
instinct slender witchfinder non mais ce
jeu est extrêmement mignon mais bon un
moment il faut trouver ou faut aller bon
alors qu'istres tu arrêtes oui tu tiens
allez hop prauthoy cette ouate tu
marches de la forêt tu croises un mec
avec une cuvette dans les toilettes
facile cuvette dans les toilettes tu
veux dans les toiles
amo l'alpage temps des on peut dormant
peu le donc j'ai pu toilettes et si on
lui donne notre billet de cinq dollars
pensée qui me laisse tranquille
what i là chapeau aux caisses naters
effet beau gosse pour nous ces partis
ont dansé un slow avec ce capteur à la
citrouille la citrouille comme on
l'apprend arnat de la vie en fait au
génial on a eu plein dit m
tiens watts il va laisser de l'argent
qu'est-ce que tu fais là lui aussi
puisqu'on des poteaux comment ça se bat
non non non salut la citrouille watts
bon je viens de cracher très bientôt ok
donc les voilà à quoi sert l'argent en
fait c'est pas pour acheter des derricks
aulas à sneijder dans d'anciens un coup
de canne est mon gars tu es tombé que
c'est moi il son visage est devenue
noire rend l'argent watts med qu'est ce
que tu as fait c'est à dire tu ta couple
avec un minotaure qu'est ce qui s'est
passé mon gars mandela l'un max d'armes
pas je veux dire on a tout de même une
sorte de boîte en bois ça va faire
sacrément regarder au delà la boîte en
bois attention la citrouille la
citrouille la cie bientôt verra stade de
rabat et une tête de paix de bière comme
ça je m'en fous j'ai assez d'argent pour
acheter un petit rigolo qui me donnera
12 points de vue attention je suis armé
des pneus de tracteur
je t'avais prévenu va chier tandja
vraiment que l'ubs a sucker punch quoi
pourquoi ce jeu crash 116 [ __ ] z'avez
vu cela des ordures et qu'on a pris le
corps d'un ogre et qu'on a pris la tête
d'un enfant de 5 ans et demi leur belle
arrrivée eux l'homme était toujours là
ce matin qu'ils ne laissent pas
tranquille cela faisait au chapeau
laisse moi tranquille chendo cela jo
végétal haï long de la vie les ennemis
l'accord g
qu'est ce que c'est pourquoi je marche
au ralenti pourquoi il n'a pas au
ralenti ce qui s'est fait une session de
schepper de prière bon j'ai sac de là je
suis perdu dans la forêt et je suis à la
recherche de cuba est-ce que tout est
normal dans le jeu laissez-moi avancé
regardez cet homme quoi est ce qui est
ce qui fait la gueule avec des nerfs
visible je sais pas regardé à al ayyat
doté par des gages aux attendait me
dites pas que alors un cas bu la tasse
un label tondeuse de la vie brottes
boîte et ça vaut bien d'autres cieux
c'est n'importe quoi
où es tu en sachant qu'elle habille cela
ne revient pas en fait c'est une sorte
de guet-apens c'est une sorte de boîte à
pain vim
c'est que cette colline sorte de
collines extra red hat et tient haut de
la colline nom n'a pas droit non saisie
c'est la boîte en bois entre tp ctos
mais qu'est ce qui te prends toi mais je
ne te permet pas les héros de vie
apparemment méchant gambetta quant à 0
de vie le jeu crash louga genre tu as 0
de vie et ben vas-y ronde et marton pc
fdp scandaleux qu'elle touche vous prend
la cuvette
ok on extrait pratique c6 c7 et touche
d'été les touches les plus loin de tes
doigts je n'ai pas de sens je m'emballe
sec tu voyages une sorte de stand-up et
glace à paraître et qui du coup a donné
une couleur sur la tête d'un coup
bourdieu à mi hauteur qui volent c'est
incroyable et c'est la cuvette images et
des lices porte sur ce jeu comme appui
vaty balade marchés envoient plus
lentement forme le manque de bras canot
tarder à nous y voilà il faut que
j'allais oublier tes de le voir ton
argent je cherche un racket
non je n'ai rien demandé j'adore ce
qu'on peut dire que c'était l'amusement
extrême
non coco le bellevue mais si gbagbo dix
ans mais qu'est ce qui lui prend comme
celle là je ne veux pas mal ton pénis
laisse moi tranquille et doit être blanc
est moche une sorte de tipp-ex battue
pourrait voir n'importe quel truc
appareil que c'est préparer quoi a salué
oui et ça va au blé pour java ou quoi
les tiac à témoin [ __ ] ses jeux de
mots t'es dingue
incroyable allez on a une page up
terminé qu'est ce que tu exactement
comme créature nokia j'arrive pas à
comprendre par jake on a mis tous les
objets qu'on avait sous la main dans un
mixeur genre un chapeau piratins
haussariat une compote et bien sathonay
tata thème regarde mon gars le japon
pirates les ont donné sa vie le costume
d'entraîneur puisqu'il a absolument
aucune personne au bon dieu c'est
l'heure du pta ok mais et c'est l'heure
de prendre ça et de attendre puisque
tant sur la touche web est emballé les
gens c'est déjà la fin de cette petite
vidéo j'espère quand même ça vous aura
plu
désolé pour la voix de canard encore une
fois et puis on se masse quitté sur un
merveilleux cadeau
allez c'est parti à de fuir et voilà
j'ai juste un chat s'appelle lula
extrêmement extrêmement vénère
actuellement peut être attaqué et bien
mettre sa patte sur le bruit des gens
as-tu déjà fait du judo constitue encore
si oui tu étais quel futur parce que je
suis ceinture bleu vert watts en éclats